I am joined now 90-day franchise fans by
Tanja and Sinjin how are you - good to
see you hi thanks for having us
yeah you know I think we're doing well
cooking looks the whole carpet thing and
everything rather than that I think
you've been doing pretty well yes so
where are you guys right now we're
currently living in Connecticut in our
new place that you'll be seeing on the
new season so you guys you know you went
on the show we loved watching you but as
everybody encounters I think when they
go on any reality show you have ups and
downs you have fan support and you have
the the fan feedback that's a little
more critical how did you feel about
doing another season were you
apprehensive I think it's definitely
different behind the scenes than like
you know we film for a long time it only
so much makes the screen so it's a good
balance of realizing of course people
are gonna be upset what they see that's
why it's a number-one show um but at the
end of the day like we know our love for
each other and we know what's going on
and yes different always hard having
having hundreds and thousands of people
you know chipping in on your
relationship giving you the relationship
advice I kind of don't know you'll set
your stylist and it gets a lot you know
so doing the second season was
definitely like oh we're gonna do this
all again but you know we did it and we
liked it and here we are so what is your
relationship status for the record for
the record right now you're gonna tell
me that okay you guys getting together
are you holding hands right now
are you together right now so right now
there's a lot of things going on and
qualify clearly stayed on that so yes
okay are you in a good place right now
you know I think I think we've both been
in a good place of mind and you know a
good a good mind state yeah I hope yeah
we're doing good well for the record you
guys are living your quarantine together
right now yes yes we are quarantine
together
okay Tonya you especially I think got
some criticism as the show aired in you
guys's first season would you guys say
that you have changed at all after
watching yourselves in your relationship
back on TV is there anything that you
learned from it and adjust it as you
watched yourselves playback you know I
that's been tough watching yourselves
you know I was definitely like going
into the next season your mind
automatically powers like these little
chicks like oh I shouldn't have said
that that might be the best but you know
like says you do you mind does go
through like situations where you lean
them you know just to check us up and
remember that this is millions of people
watching definitely probably wouldn't
have done anything too differently I
think a lot of it came from the heart
there's a lot of emotions well you guys
really kind of put yourselves through
the wringer because everybody in this
franchise deals with someone making a
big move but then singeing got here and
Tanya you had to leave to go on that I
guess I'd call it a retreat that you
went on where you were learning about
wellness um what would you say looking
back at that decision like you got a lot
of criticism for that for for leaving
him in America and I'm wondering what
you have to say to those people and if
you still stand by that decision yeah
going to Costa Rica in the middle of the
90 days of course wasn't the best option
but it was something that we both
decided before he even flew here that I
wasn't gonna cancel my trip there and
for everyone who is very upset about
that I mean I went
I did what I had to do I'm still you
know doing what I can with our herbs and
currently about to actually make a mix
tonight and I wouldn't change that for
anything you guys said also you had
those moments where Tanya you were kind
of going out and having fun and Sinjin
was wanting you to check in with him
more
seeing that back I'm wondering if that
started discussions and if the way that
you guys just check in with each other
and go out socially I know we're in a
pandemic now but has that changed at all
because that was something you really
butted heads on in terms of your
relationship communication yeah you know
I I think you'll always get the same
answer to be honest sir and it's not
that I don't check in yes you just
started it right now what has it been
like for you two to have this quarantine
time together I think it's affecting
everybody's relationships how has it
affected yours
it's a lot you know spending time with a
loved one all the time you gets a lot
you get in each other's nerves you know
sooner or later you gonna start talking
about who won't put the coffee cup in
the sink something like that like a
little free spices wrong even though
we're married and all that so it's
definitely been a little bit of bumping
heads and disagreements but for the most
of all we've seen some little moments in
the trailer but there are little moments
that are big you see you go back to
South Africa
Sinjin you I think we hear you say you
wish you've never left
and I'm wondering why that is and what
that moment feels like for you yeah so
for me it was very overwhelming you know
going back home it was a really really
crazy experience you know it really made
me feel homesick at the time you know
and I was contemplating what what this
way the right move I'm doing you know
family over here you know life in
America
you'll see a lot of things going on of
my family as well so there's a whole
backstory to all that but definitely you
know thinking whether coming to America
was the right decision or not cross my
mind so was it the right decision I
think for my immediate future yes I
think I have on the right paw
he misses being barefoot everywhere and
like ostriches running like passes house
Tania what was that like for you we see
you have kind of an emotional moment
with engines family involved how are you
feeling during that um you know yeah
there's there's definitely a mix of
emotions a lot comes out um it's almost
it was kind of a build up moment you
know I think being newlyweds and like
actually now says you know we we were
together for a year and a half before
the 90 days and we actually lived
together but even during that time it
was still it's very much vacation mode
like we were traveling and you know
there was no settling of route so you
know now that we're in that process
there's been a lot that's been coming
out and you know just questions and
wondering are we making the right
decisions are we doing the right things
are we meant to be and that kind of just
spoils over that night well that was
something that came out too with the
whole soulmate discussion for you guys
on the first season how do you feel
about that right now are you meant to be
you know that you can get I was like I
definitely know like our souls were
destined to cross paths and I definitely
met so philosophical I'm like meant to
be like what is meant to be even mean
like do I see myself like with you
forever like I do and like do I see you
being the father of children I do and do
I see like us being old and cranky old
people together waiting for a bus just
make fun of the little kids coming off
probably yeah I do yeah look Bay that
whole topic did definitely explore the
Pandora's box as they say that was a hot
topic a lot was going on you know it was
it was very tough to hear that
you know it's still something we're
looking into a little bit of a slight
open door to their conversations yeah I
will say is if relationships were built
only on love we would have the best
relationship ever but you know we're two
people we're two individual people with
our own habits and lights and just likes
and my thoughts and you know and if we
can blend all that together then we'll
see I'll be honest it's kind of sounding
like we see at some point maybe a
breakup between you two does it get to
that point yeah all right well let me
fire some stuff out you Sinjin do you
have a job right now babies were also a
topic for YouTube they have kids like I
do definitely want to raise them out
here in the States
do you want me to come in and build a
family but you don't even recognize me
is just so me where are we at with that
so yeah we the baby situation I would
stay still hanging in the closet that
doesn't make any sense he's still he's
still trying to figure it out and I'm
I'm trying to figure out how what's the
healthy boundary for me you know I'm not
gonna pressure him into having kids or
not even pressure him into making a
decision but I need to go for me like
how long do I feel comfortable waiting I
want to start planning this feature I
want to think about what's it look like
to start building and having a stable
life to bring children into this world
so and I'd like to plan that with my
husband but we'll see now it was a big
line of ass and for you guys you you you
said look like yeah this might be a deal
breaker for me
it sounds like you're still evolving it
I I don't want to be too invasive but it
sounds like it's
you're not like planning the nursery
upstairs that expecting anytime soon my
annual the other day and I'm like I have
to go back for an ultrasound babe they
like they think I may be pregnant okay
but it sounds too like that's still a
line in the sand for you Tanya and you
you keep saying it's very important for
you
it is it is I really really want
children I want to be a mom is there a
timeline on that being a deal breaker if
you aren't able to have kids in X amount
of years um not really so much like had
kids in X many years it's the fact that
like I want to start being able to plan
for that and start setting up a timeline
and it doesn't that's not possible
you know what Sinjin who doesn't it
isn't sure if he wants kids or not yeah
you know and I don't want to have my own
separate timeline for our future and so
what does that look like and that's
something I'm trying to figure out
Sinjin how do you help her figure that
out the only thing I can kind of do to
help that hug I always have no time for
him I'm not gonna wake up in the
mornings oh yeah I would like a child
today no so you know I'm trying I'm
interacting a lot more with when your
sister's baby you know just kind of
playing and see how that will be I
change the net before the first sungai
today there was some crazy-ass but we
did it so yeah I'm just trying to get
myself more familiar with children and
see that what do that does to my mind
see how I really feel I'm wondering you
Sinjin though if you um where you might
say if any if there's been progress or
forgiveness on some things that they may
be hurt either of you in the past you
know you were very hurt in that moment
where Tonya said she thought her ex
might be her soul mate have you had
moments of forgiveness or progress about
specific things that fans saw between
you two yeah yeah you know exactly like
there's a lot of ups and downs and a lot
of things will say that feelings were
hurt you know even after the scenes we
still continue the discussion the
argument still kind of kind of goes on
you know but for myself in order
for me to like kind of not sit of anger
and all that kind of stuff I have to
learn to let go and kind of understand
other people's mindsets as well and in
that it kind of takes away the stress
and anger that I feel inside me you know
it kind of sets me free so have you move
forward from that argument yeah you know
I don't wake up in the morning and
resent her about that you know as I say
it's still a topic me sometimes bring up
and still something researching into
more we we can both feel comfortable
with the end result I think you two were
both being vocal about you know even and
all the movements that are happening
right now
I what was it like for you to use your
platform there and then why did you want
to that for me was a very significant
moment you know I'm you in America right
now the huge movement is happening I'm
Tonya is the one who actually shaped my
mind
SEPA mind but introduced you know how
racism works and what really is behind
the scenes and how black and brown
people really feel and that was very
empowering for me so for me to God that
they just live and show everybody
although it looks a lot of hate for it
but I not okay you know you have to show
what you stand for you get this platform
all of a sudden out of the blue you know
when they you know more next day BAM so
you kind of you kind of want to figure
out what how's the base to use you your
breath home so I think that was just a
movement that really touches all of us
you know there's intensity out there
right now and I get what was that like
for you to walk him through and and you
know to be trying to kind of have those
conversations especially when you have a
partner who's from another country who
now is here and and there's so much
history in the u.s. with with everything
that people have been through here yeah
it's been a lot I mean I think ever
since I kind of met Sinjin we've talked
about racism and like what that is how
it shows up and it's been just ongoing
conversations and I'm going like let's
watch this documentary on Netflix and
you know so we actually watched one by
Ava called 13 and that leaf blew his
mind open so it's then I'm just grateful
that ascension is like so down to like
listen and learn and like be ready to
like think like think things through
that he probably would have never
thought for so
definitely grateful Leon coming from
South Africa it's like there's so much
that it's happened there and then you're
here and oh yeah
that's a lot to reconcile in process you
know we saw it Sonia your family a lot
on the first season
how do your mom and your your sister
feel about things with you in Sinjin at
this point your sister even kind of
sometimes seemed to have a lot of
criticism for you and and sided with
Sinjin on a lot of things yeah my sister
is definitely a huge Sinjin fan which is
good yeah oh it's really good but my mom
no my mom I swear like what my my mom
really really really likes engine and
there would be times that were like out
together for like out to eat or anything
like that we just three of us and
sometimes I feel like the third wheel
like they get along really well even
though I think something doesn't see it
sometimes I'm like no like she really
likes you like you don't notice how I
just sit here you two were talking okay
so it's like it's not good to have that
cinge it is there any chance you're
going back to South Africa this one well
yeah there's different going on so we're
gonna have to see Tonya what woody what
do you feel about that possibility um I
always been down to kind of live in
South Africa when we first met before
traveling to Thailand I was ready to
like move out to South Africa
permanently well like temporarily
permanently like a year or two I think
currently our best bet is to be here in
the States making you know the US dollar
and just really being able to save up
and then I'm kind of down to see where
the future takes us I definitely want
roots here in the States but doesn't
mean it needs to be full-time I can I
can I can reenter that comment so if I
put you with to be bad like immediate
yeah
belong to me now I would definitely like
to earn property okay
in South Africa where my family's and so
on you know that's also a big discussion
between us because I'm always like I
want to buy a property abroad before in
America first and she's America first in
abroad so okay yeah and what I'm
wondering is you know because it's such
a thing in the trailer of you guys going
back and all that I'm wondering if this
if where you live is along the same
lines of the kids thing on the
deal-breaker level like is there a
potential for where you live being a
major issue in your relationship yeah
yeah you're gonna yeah we're gonna get
into that as well quite deep you know
and now it's definitely or so thing how
emotional does this season get we saw
quite a lot from you on season one will
we see tears breakdowns what do we see
from you here this was this was for me a
very emotional roller coaster going down
back down you'll get to see the main
reason of going down and everything is a
real cliffhanger and yeah it was a very
surreal moment ups and downs you you did
let's leave a few your wife and you like
dance yeah it's definitely differently a
lot very I would say this was more
emotional than last season you were you
were questioning even returning to the
u.s. yeah well you got back here what
brought you back you know as I say um I
committed you know and I think I think
there's a there's a good future in
America right now for me and you know
good things going on you and everything
and you know obviously it's all because
of this girl next to you but you know
you that that doesn't work out I think I
will be on the first plane out of here I
don't think I'll be staying around in
America so on you guys are couples that
have been through traveling across the
world living apart doing long-distance
these really huge big things for a
relationship
and you know through it all you two are
sitting here together I'm talking you to
you here together and you're looking at
each other's eyes and you're
complimenting each other and and you can
see that you to care for each other so
what I'm wondering is just what is your
driving force what's kept you two in
each other's lives through all the ups
and downs that you've been through in
only the past couple years from travel
to car accidents to pandemics to it all
yeah you know the thing is a lot come
down to love and personal
characteristics you know I think there's
a lot of love between us I like tiny
blue she is how she goes about doing a
thing you know although I go about doing
my thing they can sometimes clash you
know but I still love who she is and
what she stands for and what she does so
there's all those hard times and
everything goes just one of the main
things that keep us going that we know
we can be great together but you just
got to figure it out yeah
[Music]